what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
you know there are some writers in this
world that are able to create just
ridiculously amazing stories I mean just
stories that are just like like holy cow
like Wow and I feel like like Tinian is
one of those guys like follow the Batman
is so good I feel like his whole Batman
run is on par with Scott Snyder those
are guys who aren't familiar with what I
mean Scott Snyder kind of reinvigorated
interest in Batman in a lot of ways like
the creation of the court of owls the
idea that there was this organization
that lived inside Gotham City are
operated in Gotham City the Batman never
knew about despite being like the
world's greatest detective the return of
the Joker who was like darker had his
face surgically removed and then just
attached it with pins death of a family
and like Batman in Game and the Justice
League being joke Erised and there were
so many great things but like I look at
this this whole run unlike Detective
Comics so far and it's just like between
between tinning and like Tom Kane I feel
like it rivals if not anse in some
instances better than scott Snyder's run
and this it's crazy
initially we pick up what a character by
the name of Anarchy now anarchy we
haven't really talked about too much and
he's kind of intriguing when you think
of the Anarchy character think about how
like Red Hood Jason Todd used to be when
he first showed up a narc he is a little
more extreme he's a lot more hardcore
than Batman is now the motivations of
Anarchy at his core is very similar to
Batman in the sense that hey criminals
need to be held accountable for the
things they say and do the difference
here is that Anarchy is willing to go to
the extreme he's actually willing to
sacrifice people if it means his goal is
achieved but by and large Anarchy was an
interest of the characters Stephanie
Brown of the character of spoiler now
with regards to Stephanie was kind of
cool because remember when it came to
her whole thing you ended up having this
scenario where Tim Drake had basically
died the or at least it was believed
that Tim Drake had died and in the
aftermath of that because Stephanie and
Tim were so close
it hit her pretty hard and it hit her so
extreme that she actually left the bat
team and went out to do her own thing
now this coincided with the original I
guess the the first story arc involving
the victim syndicate which is to say
this group of people who had banded
together under the idea they had all
basically been harmed by Batman in the
crossfire between Batman and the various
villains that he faced and so the result
was that they actually kind of you know
managed to bring Stephanie to their side
and basically have her you know take
pictures and things like that to
essentially incriminate the bat family
and to say hey look these
the kind of things of that family does
and so that's really kind of how anarchy
and and Stephanie met it's really their
distinctive ideologies in terms of how
things should be handled it ultimately
creates a kind of rift between the two
of them now of course at the same time
if this is going on we have Clayface
kind of you know watching everything
unfold and so on and so forth uh but
that's really about it now from a year
we basically pick up with Stephanie
realizing that Tim Drake has returned
and so this is a way to kind of bring
her back into the fold now of course Tim
Drake returned we covered that so you'll
find that video down in the description
but Stephanie didn't know that Tim Drake
was back and it was kind of ironic
because when he returned the first thing
he did was go to the belfry the first
thing he did was like go to the rest of
the bat family and so Stephanie was just
kind of out there still believing Tim
Drake died and this is one of the
reasons why I love the way this story is
told because it's kind of hard warming
and it's really emotional right like the
love of this girl's life has just come
back into her life effectively returned
from the dead and we're 10 Drake is just
like spilling apologies and hey look I
know I should have come here first I'm
so sorry and you know I miss you and
it's cool because it's immediately water
under the bridge it's basically look
like you're here and now and that's the
only thing that matters it's very human
now at this point we basically pick up
about three weeks later and the reason
why we jumped three on forward in time
is because what this does is it
basically has a guy by the name of
Killer Moth more or less he's a b-level
villain is really all it is he's not
that interesting at all but the funny
thing about this is that over the course
of these three weeks Tim Drake has been
hard at work now that's one thing to
keep in mind one of the things that was
established in like JLA number 86 I
think it was is that Tim Drake is in a
lot of ways second to Batman when it
comes to being a detective and one of
the things that's been confirmed here in
DC rebirth is that when enough time
passes Tim Drake will actually surpass
Batman as a detective and become better
than Bruce Wayne that's really kind of
been the famous suit you know really
evolved around his character for a
number of years and that's one of the
reasons why fans didn't really like
seeing Tim Drake leave the role of Robin
is because they were hoping that logical
scenario would unfold itself which and
rebirth it looks like they're kind of
riding that ship and it looks like it's
going in that direction but the idea
here is that under the guidance of Tim
Drake the bat family has become more
militarized organized I guess is the
best way to say it but the result is
that is effectively like smashed crime
in Gotham City
and so the result is that all these
different mob bosses are losing money
hand over fist and so where normally
they never would have
entertain the notion of meeting with
Killer Moth who supposedly has this
miracle plan for being able to take out
the bat family what they do is a sin you
know liaisons more or less to go check
these guys out and it is cool because
where they do have solomon grundy at
their disposal what we find out is of
course solomon grundy is being played by
by Clayface now again this hits of the
nature of play phases character it hits
the nature of what he's capable of and
it's a really cool thing because with
Clayface being roll over into the bat
family and really the first step in
Batman's attempt to see if it's possible
to essentially reform villains turn them
into good guys and put them to use
Clayface is probably the most beneficial
asset to the team because Clayface is in
a lot of ways indestructible I mean he's
got a few weaknesses you know super cold
temperatures you know like the ice gun
of mr. freeze different things like that
there are weaknesses that he has but in
terms of Clayface you know going against
these various villains that exists out
there not very many of them would be
able to stop him not only that his
ability to shape-shift makes him an
invaluable asset because he could
effectively infiltrate almost any
organization if they manage to subdue
one of that organizations members and
then have Clayface show up in that purse
instead so again he's a huge benefit to
the team in a lot of waste but the whole
idea behind his character was really
more of like an evolution like I mean
when it came to this story it was so
cool because Clayface had been a villain
of Batman for years and years and years
and years and the idea or writer coming
along and saying let's make him a good
guy let's see what would happen it
creates some fantastic storytelling now
of course this brings Batman is a direct
conflict with mayor mayor Aikens and for
the most part it's just this idea that
Akers is kind of like look the biggest
problem that we have right now is the
city believes that you're the one who
saves the day and they have virtually no
faith in the police department is
effectively the mayor trying to restore
faith in the people's ability to believe
this city can effectively save them and
so it worked it's actually pretty
intriguing the cool thing about this too
is it also sees the Reformation of the
victims syndicate these first victims of
Batman so of course it kind of leads
into the idea of them launching their
own campaign now it is really intriguing
because for the character of Tim Drake
this is almost an obsession and the
funny thing about this is it Stephanie
doesn't really know the motivations of
Tim Drake in her mind Stephanie believes
that they will basically how the Tim
Drake will set the entire belfry in
motion so it effectively be autonomous
in the sense that it'll be nothing more
than just calculations and formulas so
all the bad family has to do is just
press some buttons or what
you work basically work within a system
that effectively takes care of itself
and there's no more need for Tim Drake
if there is no more need for Tim Drake
in the belfry that Stephanie at Tim
Drake can effectively ride off into the
sunset which is what she's wanted all
along Stephanie never wanted to be part
of the bad family long term and so it's
interesting because she sees Tim Drake
as an out in the sense that they can
find happiness together the funny thing
about this is that for Tim Drake this is
his life remember a Tim Drake is like
the second longest running Rob and I'm
pretty sure Tim Drake is an intricate
part of the Batman family I mean when
when Jason Todd died you know after dick
grayson went on to become Nightwing
Batman became more extreme and so Tim
Drake him being a sidekick to Batman is
not just about superhero escapades he's
invested he was bringing Batman back
from the edge of self-destruction
because Batman was close to like going
in the process of killing villains
because he was so crushed by the death
of Jason Todd he's invested in the life
of Bruce Wayne because he helped to
bring him back and when you're that
intertwined with the bat family you
can't just walk away and that's Tim
Drake's whole stance this culminated
with the fact that there was his future
self who basically said look I am the
person you're going to become almost
brings him to sharp relief this ideology
that Tim Drake's future is set in stone
but Tim Drake has basically seen his
future and he's trying to avoid that
future but if he knows in that future
he's going to be Batman then at this
point the question is how how can he
control how that future unfolds and
that's was so cool because that's the
motivating factor that's what all this
is for is to basically create a better
future so that when he becomes Batman
even though he says he doesn't believe
he will be it's creating a system that
works so he won't become a villain now
the other half of this is that with this
system there's all these different ideas
in these schemes and he's got dozens and
dozens of ideas rolling through his head
but we can have this specialized system
set up we can have different bad signals
that go up in the air so that we could
say okay well that woman's got her own
signals so she's got this crisis taken
care of over here cool I can go over
there and Batman's already over there
it's like this massive conglomerate
system designed to hit home at the idea
that Tim Drake has it all figured out
that it's a self-sustaining system now
the other half of this is that Stephanie
Brown figured out pretty fast that Tim
Drake was basically lying about the idea
that they're all gonna have this great
life together and they're gonna settle
down and it's kind of intriguing because
she basically kind of feels betrayed in
this instance like I thought we were
gonna have this life together and in
truth you've been
be me the entire time but it's kind of
like this giant spill of secrets it's
this idea that Tim Drake kind of
confronted with the fact that she was
taking pictures for the victims
syndicate and so it's really kind of
like this airing of grievances which is
really kind of you know an indication of
the honeymoon phase is over but it is
intriguing because Stephanie kind of
walks and says look I'm gonna go cool
off I'll decide what it is that I'm
gonna end up doing next so at this point
we pick up with Clayface who's visiting
Gloria now I remember we talked about
Gloria before Gloria was a girl that
Clayface was a really really good friend
with and I believe there was a little
bit of a romantic chemistry there the
issue is that when he first became
Clayface she was caught in the crossfire
between Clayface and Batman and the
result was that she was doused with the
same kind of clay or the same kind of
material that Clayface was sitting her
into the same position he's in the
difference is that she kind of gave in
to her darker side she sort of gave up
she couldn't control her powers in the
same way he could and she's been
dominated by violence ever since she
first became this the kind of person
that she is and so the result was that
she was one of the people who joined the
victim syndicate now this is one of the
first times you began to see this
instance where the possibility was being
teased at Clayface would go back to
being a villain now that's not the case
we haven't seen that so far but it is
intriguing because what this means is
that at this point going forward
Clayface is kind of stuck in this rut
because what is up happening is that
where he's conversing with Gloria and
basically offering all these apologies
and saying look I'm sorry I screwed up
you know but there's a doctor that we
have dr. October who's working on a cure
and maybe she can send you back to your
normal form Gloria's response is no I
don't want to go back to the person that
I am I want people to see how you are to
see your true self and so ultimately we
end up finding out that the victim
syndicate has effectively taken over
Arkham Asylum all the guards are working
for them and they in turn subdue
Clayface and it's almost crushing to see
this happen because Clayface is begging
he's like look you know don't let people
see me like this you know like why do
you keep doing this I'm trying to make
up for the mistakes that I've made and
so it's almost like he's just kind of
being betrayed over and over and over
again it's basically just kicking a
person while they're down and that's why
it's so you know so distraught here is
because with everybody basically
responding to what's going on you know
like - the Gotham police department
responding and the bat family becoming
aware of the fact that you know Arkham
Asylum has been taking over a reporter
basically enters you know this this
Arkham Asylum at the request of the
victim syndicate and one of the first
things that we end up seeing here is
that there is this instance where
Clayface is just kind of being brutally
tortured over and over again it's so sad
see because normally we would see him
just like lash out and just totally
obliterate this girl but there's sadness
and there's anger on both sides this
chick like she's just lashing out at all
the pain that she feels but the same
thing with Clayface like he feels
genuine sorrow he feels genuine sadness
and genuine remorse for the things that
he's done but he's not being given the
chance to allow his apology to be
accepted instead it's just look I'm
sorry for what I've done and then BAM
he's tortured again so I mean it's it's
pretty brutal and it's pretty extreme
because what he has is this kind of
gauntlet of sorts that allows him to
maintain some measure of control over
himself the issue is that with that
being out of his hands he's going to
revert back to who he is before and
that's what he's so terrified of it's
going back to being the old Clayface
it's kind of crushing in terms of how
all this happens now of course this also
leads into the idea of some inner
struggles going on with a bat family in
the sense that again the future version
of Tim Drake basically said bat woman's
gonna blow the family apart something's
going to happen at some point in the
future and that woman's going to do
something that's going to destroy the
bat family it's really kind of like
Tinian saying hey look guys there's
still this underlying current of things
that are taking place there's underlying
current of themes that are going on now
of course this also brings a bat family
and direct conflict with the mayor
because with Arkham Asylum having been
taken over its is really standard
practice the bat family would respond I
mean we would expect that before any of
that happens the mayor calls up Batman
on the red phone that really only
Commissioner Gordon is supposed to be
able to access and simply says stay away
get out of here we'll keep this under
control we'll take care of the situation
on our own again trying to demonstrate
in the eyes of the people that the
Gotham City Police Department can handle
things on their own now of course when
Batman shows up Commissioner Gordon is
like okay what's up with this victim
send me kids it's kind of interesting
because remember Batman and Commissioner
Gordon have a rapport and so it's really
kind of like Batman and Commissioner
Gordon and then everybody else in Gotham
City in terms of the political positions
and the police department and so on and
so forth and so if Commissioner Gordon
wants to allow Batman to go through then
Commissioner Gordon will let him go
through but it's one of those things
where it's like okay look I'm Gordon
I'll turn a blind eye because I know
that you do more good than you do harm
and that's the important thing to bear
in mind now of course Bruce is also
perfectly aware of the fact that what
the victim syndicate wants him to do is
to unmask himself that goes back to
their first appearance that was the
initial demand they had but the whole
idea is that we end up finding out the
victims syndicate has been recruiting
people that effectively they've been
traveling around the city of Gotham and
grabbing all these individuals who were
harmed by the bat family in some form or
fashion
now a lot of this is predicated
on Clayface right like the victim
syndicates basically saying look Batman
went out and he grabbed a villain and
he's trying to turn him into a good guy
but are we okay with this and the people
are like no there's like why are we not
okay with this it's like because
Clayface has done harm to us there's
things that he's done that can't be made
up for it by trying to be a good guy you
know and so because that a lot of people
are angry like they're upset they're mad
because it feels like Batman is trying
to take all these villains who have done
terrible things remove them from the
consequences of their actions and just
turn them into good guys and use them
for his own cause these people feel as
though they're being denied justice and
that's why they're all lashing out the
way they are now of course the funny
thing about this is that the head of the
victim syndicates like look Batman like
there's like a hundred cops here do you
really believe you could take all of us
out in Batman's responses yep Andi does
that's exactly what happens Batman
wrecks them all now of course we end up
finding out this was a ruse this was a
distraction and the reason why is
because the quote-unquote torture of
Clayface more or less is complete in the
sense that he shows up as a bad guy as a
villain and there's simply just like
this is who I am this is what I'm about
now on the surface we could argue
Clayface is just kind of reverted back
to his old form and that's really about
it and the fight between Batman and
Clayface it's pretty par for the course
Batman dodging his attacks his Clayface
you know using turning his fists and
stuff and you know giant hammers and
things like that there's not a lot that
goes on there of course Batman is
basically thrown into the the armory of
the various villains who were arrested
and thrown into Arkham Asylum he uses
the freeze gun of mr. freeze and then
freezes Clayface but this is when we
find out this is just kind of like a
proxy the actual Clayface is on his way
to the belfry now this is where things
get intriguing and where they get really
interesting because the response of a
few members of the back family is well
we have to take out Clayface like I mean
we've got to find a way to subdue him
now they all want to do it in a way
that's not you know fatal because I mean
Clayface is a part of their team this is
compounded by the argument that dr.
October makes where she basically says
this is not Clayface returning to a
villain this is Clayface putting on like
an outer shell he's basically just a guy
who's scared that he's going to go back
to being a villain but in his fear he
becomes a villain he becomes the person
that he's most the most afraid of being
now of course dr. October had been
working on this cure the problem with
this is that it is a quote unquote cure
for a substance that they don't fully
understand and they have no idea what
the effect will be so it's really a shot
in the dark but it's one of the best
shot
they have at least until Batwoman meets
with her father I remember her father
was the one who was leaving the colony
that was the first story of Detective
Comics and rebirth when he had
essentially launched this mission to
basically infiltrate the bat family take
out the bat family and then confiscate
all their weapons and used it to create
a militarized task force in Gotham City
and of course the colony was defeated
Tim Drake was presumed to have been
killed in the onslaught and that's why
you know most people believed he was
dead but the idea was that where her
father was arrested and eventually was
able to make his escape he has offered
himself as a bit of an advisor capacity
for bat woman the problem with this is
he shows up and he says this is a weapon
that's been made by a member of the
colony which will basically kill
Clayface what it'll do is it'll
essentially keep his particles or keep
his molecules from being able to like
reform so basically it'll be like
shattering glass this will kill him but
the issue is that they're in a position
where that option kind of needs to be
entertained and that shows the
difference between bat woman and
everybody else because nobody else in
the bat family would really take that
step but for a bat woman she doesn't
necessarily Shia share that same motive
she's pretty extreme in a lot of
different ways and so the result here is
that she's really entertaining this idea
that if it comes down to it she will
kill Clayface and that's what's so
brutal about this is because what isn't
happening his orphan initially stands in
the way of Clayface himself largely
because of the fact that she's like look
you're not going to attack me and
initially he does and actually he begins
to kind of calm down now a lot of this
is because of the fact that both orphan
and Clayface are effective villains
reforming themselves so they share a
kind of bond that nobody else really has
the problem with this is that in his
massive attack we end up having all this
different clay from the mud room
basically slide down directly on a
Clayface himself now when it comes to
the mud room this is basically the
training room of the various members of
the bat family for those guys who don't
know the whole idea of the of the mud
room was basically Tim Drake going
around to various crime scenes where
Clayface had engaged in different
actions and then collecting little
pieces of the clay residue and then
essentially having gallons and gallons
of the stuff so that they could in turn
use it for a room that could shape-shift
into a variety of different things it
could spawn different villains all kinds
of cool stuff it was actually a pretty
genius idea but the problem with this is
that it is all made of the same material
that Clayface is made of and so in his
attack and in his onslaught he's
suddenly covered in all this clay
Clayface basically goes insane because
he has this massive amount of clay that
suddenly attached to him and he doesn't
know how to handle it all because it's
essentially more than his mind can keep
up with and to
of controlling his body's physical
structure and so he literally just kind
of loses his mind and suddenly just goes
out into the city of Gotham now this is
all the intention of the victim
syndicate the first victim the problem
with this is that the first victim is
willing to line up all these innocent
people and kill them all off or allow
Clayface to kill them all to show this
is what Clayface really is this is the
kind of person that Batman's willing to
rehabilitate this is the danger that the
Bat family poses in their recklessness
in trying to cure villains the issue
with this is that this is a little too
extreme for anarchy remember anarchy is
not necessarily a villain he's just a
guy who's willing to go to a few more
extremes than Batman is but there's even
a limit to his willingness he's not
really willing to allow innocent people
to die for a senseless cause like this
to say see how bad that that family is
and so ultimately anarchy basically
turns on the first victim and is able to
subdue them pretty quickly you know
pretty easily now of course but that
family responds as we would expect them
to in the sense that they're all Disko
we got to launch every single weapon at
our disposal we got to do everything we
can now the Cure is implemented by
orphen and it is actually pretty cool
because the idea is that she's got two
injected in what passes for the brain
stem of Clayface basically anywhere in
his head and so because of that when
orphan shows up she basically in you
know injects it directly into the mind
of Clayface himself which really kind of
brings him down so it is interesting
because we get this moment where he
returns back to his normal self the
problem with this is he's put on so much
mass in terms of all the clay that's
been absorbed ahem played as dr. October
explains it it's like a spring you can
compute and compact that spring but
after a while all that potential injury
is gonna build up and it's gonna spring
back out again and that's exactly what's
gonna happen with Clayface despite the
ability to cure him momentarily all this
clay that he's absorbed is basically
going to re-emerge and take back over
again and so this cure was designed for
the purpose of orphan appealing to
Clayface and saying look man you have to
regain control of yourself it's gonna be
hard it's gonna be insanely difficult
but you have to find a way to control
yourself and this is cool
because what it does is it opens the
door for the possibility of Clayface
becoming more powerful than he was
before exercising more control over
himself than he ever thought possible
pushing the mental limits of what he's
capable of and again it really kind of
like beefs up the role that he could
have in a bath family unfortunately it
doesn't matter because Batwoman pulls
the trigger and shoots Clayface in the
head with this gun that was designed to
disperse his atoms all over the place
and keep
from reforming effectively killing him
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop all like I
know sort of man through some of you
guys off I know some of you guys are
just like you guys you guys timed it and
then and then I waited just to throw you
guys off man though cliffhangers okay I
will catch you guys later peace
[Music]